hey friend is a everything okay good
just [ __ ] you sure buddy
hey Ana do the end what happened what
did you do to Ellen oh yes that's name
you get I didn't do anything to Elliott
he was crying when I got here I mean you
want a cake pop I just took some in
French ah the hell did you guys do - I
want to say Elmore Elisha and Kahlan was
Rudy you can't even remember Elliot's
name I don't think his name is Elliot oh
my god hey is it a office blues was it
the boss lady is it your penis I just
feel like if I had a penis and something
yeah but I'd crime know we're a little
dicks like big dicks Ling
sorry why aren't we working what did you
muttonchops due to poor Elliot this time
oh I've been saying that what happened
nothing happened
okay he was crying when I got here like
I tried to help he was crying when I got
here - but I closed my door and let him
cry in peace gave him some dignity I'm
just I'm sorry everyone I just know okay
we don't have to explain your emotions
man just ride them out I think uh uh
this is a safe space a safe productive
space
just forget it happen man you know what
I think if I talked about no time for
tears if you insist on crying I guess
you can do it in my office okay
really
has he even stopped to go to the
bathroom
I just been working it out tell us
what's going on my cat got eaten by
another cat oh my gosh that sounds
awesome
you